- [Interviewer] All right, Nikki.
Nikki, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Culver city.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
Had both of your parents growing up?
- I did, up until I was nine,
that's when my parents split
up but they didn't divorce.
My dad got a house in South Central,
and my mom moved to Korea town.
- [Interviewer] And you went with her?
- Initially went with my
mom, and then I was 15
and my mom got pregnant and I
wasn't too happy about that.
So, I was doing private
Catholic all girls school.
And that helped with the
rebellion, I guess like-
- [Interviewer] It often does.
- So my mom,
as soon as she had the baby
she kind of like kicked me out,
and had to go to my dad.
So I guess for two years from
then on, I was at my dad's.
I got kicked out of private school,
and things kind of just went
downhill from there. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] What kind
of stuff were you doing
as a teenager?
- I guess it was like the
weed smoking that really like
you know, tipped everything like over.
And it was the weed,
I guess my dad really
didn't like that either.
So it was harder for me
obviously to like, you know, hide
like getting high and like,
you know, being at home.
- [Interviewer] What, I mean,
were there any traumatic
events in your childhood?
Any abuse?
- My dad was really
abusive towards my mom.
There was a lot of domestic
violence, like a lot.
I'm surprised my mom, like, you know,
lasted so long with him.
But they always say it's
like, they did it for you.
- [Interviewer] But nothing
directed at you directly?
- No, not really.
I think being like the only
child up until I was 15,
like my parents being, you
know, first time parents,
I think they did pretty well as far as me.
Them not, you know, not
so much, but my dad..
My parents did kind of like, you know,
resort to like spanking
and stuff like that.
I don't agree with that kind of stuff.
You know, I think there's
other ways of, you know,
teaching your kids how
to do the right thing,
but I think that's
definitely one of the things
that also, you know,
pushed me over, you know.
I remember once my dad like,
once I had moved into my
dad's, it was like a weekend.
So I was like home all day,
and he didn't really
let me go out too much.
Like at my mom's, like, she was caring
for my little sister, you
know, when she was born.
So, at 15 that's when my mom,
like my mom used to be really strict.
So when my sister was born like that
it all literally just stopped.
Like, you know, I came
home one day the next day,
and I'd never done that before.
And like, I was scared, you know,
I was like, "Oh my gosh,
there's gonna be consequences."
And literally nothing happened.
And that's kind of when I was like, okay,
things are different.
This is (expletive) weird, you know.
But my dad..
So I was home one weekend,
and I was smoking weed,
but I didn't smoke weed that day.
And I'd been home,
and my dad was like
also a raging alcoholic.
So, he was usually always drinking,
and he came into my room and
he swore that I was high.
He was like, "Oh my God,
you're (expletive) high."
Like, and I'm like, "No, I'm not.
Like I've been here all day.
Like, you should know this."
You know?
But he was (expletive) drunk, you know?
So he kind of like beat the (expletive)
out of me for like no
reason, cause I was not high.
And that's like one of
like the biggest memories
I have of like getting spanked,
but like slash beaten cause it was bad.
And my dad is a big guy.
He's like 6"3.
And I was, I had just turned actually 16.
Yeah. That was (expletive).
- [Interviewer] And you
left home at what age?
- I'm sorry?
- [Interviewer] You left home at what age?
- As soon as I was like 18. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you go?
- I-
- [Interviewer] You dint
go to school, college?
- I moved in with my
best friend and her pimp,
and he was our age too.
So he was like also young,
and they had an apartment.
So like I lost touch with my best friend
from like middle school to all
high school until I was 18.
And then I just, you know,
we would keep in touch
through Facebook, and I
started seeing like, you know,
she had all these shopping bags.
Like she had, like, it was
clear, like she had an apartment,
but there was like no
furniture and just like a ton
of bags from like Gucci, and
Louis Vuitton, and like Prada,
and like, I couldn't help,
but like ask her like
what the (expletive) are you doing?
Where's all this money coming from?
And she like agreed to, she's like,
"Let's meet up", you
know, like we'll talk.
And at the time I was working
for somebody and I was, I had a work car,
like it was my boss's
car that I was driving.
Like during lunch I could
go and like, you know,
get lunch or whatever
in the car and stuff.
So it was a..
I had a lunch break,
and I met up with them
by Hamilton High School.
We met up behind Hamilton.
Cause we were like, we were from the area.
Like, we went to Palms Middle School,
and like Marvis Del Culver area.
And yeah, like she pulls up in
a (expletive) Porsche Cayenne
with like her pimp.
And it's literally just her and him,
and I'm already like jaw dropped,
like what the (expletive)?
Like, this is crazy.
Like, this is not just any
kind of money, you know?
And yeah.
And she told me, she's like, yeah, like,
and I was kind of just like,
I didn't know what to say.
I didn't know what to do,
like that wasn't, you know, me, you know,
and of course like her
pimp was like, you know,
obsessed with me.
Like, please like, come on,
like, let's try this out.
And I didn't, you know,
I didn't, I was like, no.
Like I can't, have to go back to work.
And she's like, dude,
(expletive) work. (chuckles)
Like, I just can't like, it's
not even my car, you know?
And yeah, like, I guess
like, I guess I would say
within like a week or two,
I like quit my job.
Like, I went to stay with them.
I like packed the bag or something,
and I just went over there.
They had an apartment off of Palms,
which was down the street
from my middle school where
like I had first met her.
And it's kind of where I grew up too.
So it was like, I don't know.
I thought I like was loving it.
You know, I was like back in Culver city.
I was with my best friend
from middle school and yeah
that's kind of, when all kind of started.
- [Interviewer] So when you
started to actually working
as a prostitute it was where?
On the street? On Figueroa?
- So it was, we started,
I started on Western
- [Interviewer] Same neighborhood?
- Yeah. Oh no, no, no, no.
Like more like Hollywood area.
- [Interviewer] Oh Hollywood.
A lot of girls work Western
by South Central and then
there's also a Western-
- Right. We did that.
And then we would also do
Supulveda in the Valley.
And I did do Fig, but Fig
was too intense for me.
And my pimp saw that.
That it was like, not just that,
but like all the other
pimps would kind of like,
you know, try and like harass me.
And, because I was just, I was
like fresh meat, literally.
He thought it would just be a better idea
to keep me towards like
the Valley and Western area
towards Hollywood, just because
maybe it wasn't as intense.
But I think it was, there
was like no difference to me.
It was all (expletive) intense and crazy.
And just, but..
- [Interviewer] So the money
you would make would go to him?
- So yeah. So when I
moved in, he was like,
he was really cool I wanna say,
like, I wasn't scared of him, you know?
He wasn't violent. Not
that I saw anything.
I do know that with
her he did get violent,
cause that was his bottom, you know,
like that was his only
girl, his bottom girl,
like his everything, his
girlfriend, everything, you know?
I do remember seeing her with
like black eyes and like,
but I never, you know, I don't know.
I tried to be as good, you know,
good with him and follows rules as much
as possible to like avoid
all that (expletive).
And I guess if I had to,
I would kinda just go along
with what he would say
even if it was kind of like
siding with him, you know?
Which started to not work
out with my best friend.
She started to like really dislike that.
But, when I first moved in,
he just asked nicely, you know, like just,
"You're just gonna give
me all your credit cards,
you know, all the cash you
have all the money you have,
and I'm just gonna hold onto it. You know?
Like whatever happens, you know,
like you'll eventually get your
(expletive) back, you know?"
You know, I didn't really
ask too many questions.
It was all just kind of, I
mean it was self-explanatory,
I wasn't, you know, a little
girl anymore, you know,
but, it was a little
nerve wracking, you know,
like, I'm making all this money
and it's just going there.
And I never, you know,
I never had any cash
in my pocket, you know?
Unless we would like go
shopping or something,
but she would always get
like more money than I would.
And even though sometimes
I would make more money
than her, you know? Like, so..
- [Interviewer] But how much
money were you collecting?
- So we would have like a
certain amount, you know,
like we'd have to come back
with at least a 1000 a night.
And I remember at the beginning, like,
I didn't know that, you
know, because I started
off on Western, and Fig, and Supulveda,
and all those places,
like I thought, you know,
I thought a 100 bucks was enough
from one person, you know,
but then I met this, you know,
this one guy on Supulveda,
and when he asked me, you know,
how much I needed or whatever.
And I told him, like, I
thought I was like, you know,
he had a bad (expletive)
car and like, he got a room,
that the first time I
got a room, you know,
we got a room with one
with one of these guys.
Like, it wasn't like a car
date or anything like that.
And so I was like, okay, I
can't ask for a 100 bucks.
Like, it's gotta be way more than that.
So I asked them for $300 and
he just like, stayed quiet.
And he was like, "You're joking, right?"
And I'm like, well, is I'm
like, "Is that too much?"
Like, I'm like, "I'm sorry.
Like, I don't know,
like what do you have?"
You know?
And I realized like, I was
asking for not enough. Right?
Like I was..
I should have asked for
a lot more, I guess.
And, I guess that's kind
of when I started to also
realize like, you know, you just go,
kind of trial and error along the way.
Like, no one's really
like (expletive) teaching
you anything, you know?
You're just kind of-
- [Interviewer] There's
no school for this.
- Not at all. So, yeah.
I remember that day, I had made
enough way before my sister
or whatever, and I kind
of just like stayed
on the street until it was time,
because I didn't think
I was allowed to go back
or like make any calls, you know?
Until like she did for
something, I don't know.
Like, I didn't really
know what was going on.
So, I waited, I stayed out all
night when I didn't have to,
because I already had the $1000, you know?
And when he realized like,
you know, finally we,
so we met up at a Denny's,
me and her, like, we met up,
and then we went to Denny's,
and then he came and picked us
up there, and we had
breakfast and, you know,
and I guess he realized like I
had finished way before time.
And he was like, "What the (expletive)?
Like, why don't you
(expletive) say something like,
you know?"
That was kind of like the
only time I kind of saw
him (expletive),
but he (expletive) was for
like a good reason I guess.
- [Interviewer] You're working too hard.
(Nikki laughs)
- And so that was when he
decided to send me to Hawaii.
Yeah. And then that's kind of when
I started traveling a little bit for work
- [Interviewer] And you make
better money when you travel?
- Yeah. I mean,
so yeah.
I mean, Hawaii's is,
it's almost legal.
I wanna say, you know,
it's a huge strip in
Waikiki where they're all
over the place, you know,
there's girls everywhere.
No one's really like hiding
from the cops like here,
you know, like you see a cop car,
and you like have to duck behind
trash cans and (expletive).
Like, and out there, it
wasn't really like that.
You just have to be careful,
you know, with who you were,
you know, getting into cars
with and stuff like that.
But there was definitely
more money traveling.
- [Interviewer] So you're making
the money, but you're still
giving it-
- Still not, still nothing
in my bank account. (laughs)
No. Yeah no, like, you know, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Did the idea
at some point come to you,
like you could do this without a pimp?
- Yeah. There was times where
I wanted to pocket some money
you know, stash it, you know,
I'm like, "I can stash it right now,
like I have a chance
to do that right now."
But I was scared, you know,
everything was going so good.
I didn't wanna (expletive)
that up for myself.
So I never did. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And this
relationship with the pimp lasted
for how long?
Or is it still going on?
- So, I eventually got into
a car with an undercover cop.
This was also in Hawaii.
I was making a (expletive) ton
of money, like stupid money.
- [Interviewer] How much
were you making a night?
- I could make up to like 2000 a night.
And, I mean to me that
was a lot because here,
you know, you make, you know,
your dates were like
60 $8 dates, you know,
and out there you could
do, you know, 350 for like
as much as you could.
You know, I realized that
the number did only mattered,
you know, depending on who I was seeing,
and who I was meeting
and, you know, over time
you start to realize these things.
And so you kind of start
putting your price on things,
you know, as you go.
And yeah.
And so we had a room
that we were all sharing,
but the day that that happened,
he and her packed all their
bags and like left the room.
I managed to talk my way out of that.
I don't know how, but when I..
So I called her,
I didn't have any ID on me.
This cop, this undercover
cop actually ended up calling
my mom.
Cause he could tell, you know, I wasn't,
I hadn't been doing this for very long.
And, of course I (expletive)
along the way a lot.
Like I'm just here with
a friend, like, you know,
I kinda made it seem like I
didn't know what was going on,
but like, you know, of course
I did, but like I didn't,
(chuckles) to him.
And so he was like, look like, you know,
basically, to him, it was
like I was forced to do this.
You know, like, I, you
know, I didn't have to,
and I didn't want to, like
that's kind of like how
I played it out to him.
And so he was like, "Okay, look like
I'm gonna call your mom, just
call your mom and you know,
tell her to get you a ticket back home.
You need to get the
(expletive) out of here."
And he's like, "As long as
you can just show me an ID,
like have somebody bring an ID,
like I'm not gonna do anything.
Just like, I need to see who you are."
And you know, I called,
you know, I called her.
And she brought, she
had to go to the house.
So she had to stop working.
She had to go to the
hotel room, get changed.
You know, she had to get
out of like her (expletive)
like baby doll that she was in,
(expletive) put some
sweats on or something,
and came and like brought
me up my ID, my passport.
And the whole time, she's just
like furious I could tell.
And she was scared at
the same time, you know,
because she thought, you know,
something that could happen
to her, you know, she could
get arrested or something.
Because obviously, you know,
the cop's not stupid, you know,
he knows what's going on,
but he did what he said he
would, you know, and he got..
She brought my ID.
He let her leave and he talked to my mom,
and then he let me go.
So, by the time I got back to the room,
she was already gone.
Everybody was gone,
nobody was in the room.
So they had left me
instructions on what to do,
like, okay, you're gonna
grab your (expletive),
gonna get out of that room,
and you're gonna go to
this other hotel room.
You're gonna get another room.
And you're going to work there
by herself without, you know,
without the other girl.
And that was the first for me, you know,
like I hadn't worked by myself, you know,
I didn't have my own room ever.
I, you know, everything like,
it was scarier for me,
because I was alone.
I felt alone. I felt
like they had completely
abandoned me.
They didn't, you know,
they were still in Waikiki.
Like, but that's when I guess like,
kind of like my depression started
to kind of kick in a little bit.
And I felt like betrayed, you know?
Like, she kind of like, they
both left my side, you know?
And as much as I, you
know, told them that, like,
you know, like I didn't
say anything, you know,
I didn't say any names. I
didn't say anything about you
or him or anything.
They just, you know, they
weren't like having it.
And that was also when I was
like, well, I have a room now.
Maybe I could start stashing some money.
And like, but I still never did it.
And like, I just didn't. I don't know.
I don't know. I guess at that point,
I don't know if this was
his thing, like, you know,
our pimp's thing, like, I
felt that was when he started
kind of having like favorites, you know?
Cause we were never in the
same room at the same time.
And he would say certain things to me,
and I'm sure he would say
certain things to her.
And,
I don't think my relationship
changed with him.
Like I didn't feel different towards him,
but I felt something
had changed, you know,
as far as our relationship.
And then that was also kind of when he,
I started to see, you know,
other sides of him, you know?
And I guess, yeah, I guess
that was when I graduated
from like new fresh
meat to like, you know,
really like being out, like, you know,
10 toes down, like legitimately,
and like just not having
anybody, you know,
behind me or besides me, or, you know,
helping me or anything, you know?
But I don't know. I mean,
I wouldn't change anything
about it, you know,
it's..
I learned a lot, you know,
I've met a lot of people.
It was, I mean, I was in Hawaii.
It's like my first time out in Hawaii.
So, that was cool.
I mean, without that, I
did eventually go in Hawaii
with like family and friends
and stuff, but you know,
at 18 that wasn't, you
know, that was like, whoa,
like you know, making
money and I'm by myself.
I mean, I don't have any
money in my bank account,
but I'm like shopping every day and like..
- [Interviewer] So that
relationship lasted how long?
- So that lasted..
After that, I think they
were both really uneasy
with me because they really
thought that I had said
something about them.
They thought that I had
kind of like thrown them
under the bus to like, get
out of this thing, you know?
And-
- [Interviewer] Because
you got away so easy.
- Right. But I didn't, I
mean, I never, you know-
- [Interviewer] You just met a nice cop.
- Yeah. Just felt sorry for me.
Legit like he just felt sorry for me.
Cause I looked like such a
deer in headlights out there,
you know?
And I thought, and you
know, I thought, you know,
I thought that would be a temporary thing.
Like, okay.
Like, you know, maybe
in like a couple of days
we'll get another suite again
and I'll be able to go back
with them, but that never happened.
And she also started kind
of getting a little, like,
you know, uneasy about things.
Like she thought that..
Cause when you, you know,
when you're the only one,
you're the only girl to a pimp, like,
you don't have to worry about, you know,
other girls or like having, you know,
your pimp having favorites
or like, you know,
is he spending more money
on her and da, da, da?
She never had that, you know?
Like she was the only one
ever making money issues.
She was cute little
Korean girl, she's Korean.
She, you know, I remember
they used to call her
like a trap star because she
would make so much money.
You know?
Like everybody on Western knew her.
Like, you know?
She was like very well known.
And I guess, you know, I was
making good amounts of money.
So she kinda started to
feel uneasy about it.
And I think she had a
lot to do with like him
kind of like distancing himself from me.
Not that he like had fired
me or told me to go home
or anything.
Cause like, why would he do that?
I'm a temporary bankroll for him.
You know, like..
- [Interviewer] You were a threat.
- Well for her.
Yeah. Right, yeah.
But, eventually I felt it was like
our relationships had changed
so much that I was like,
I need to go back to LA.
Like, I can't do this out
here anymore by myself.
Like, I feel so alone, you know?
And so, that's when I, you
know, that's when I asked him
like, within like two weeks
after that incident happened,
which had been like a week
and a half into us being
out there, I told him that, you know,
I wanted to go back
home. I couldn't do it.
Unless he was gonna put
us back in the same room.
He was like, "That's not
(expletive) happening."
Like the (expletive).
So I was like, "Well,
then I wanna go home."
You know? And he didn't
argue with me or anything.
He, you know, he was like,
took me shopping the next day.
And like, he was like, "Okay."
Like I guess he was like,
"Are you sure? Like, is this
really what you want to do?"
Like we had gone shopping
and like, no, yeah,
this is still, you know,
like I still wanna go back.
And he just like, even...
I told him, even when I get back,
and I'm still down to work
when I get back, you know?
But he, I guess for
him it was more of like
a commitment thing.
Like, you know, you're
all in or not, you know,
like I guess he felt
like me being out here,
and working Western and Fig
was like half (expletive)
for me.
Like, if I was gonna be working for him,
he wanted me like all in,
like making (expletive)
thousands in Hawaii, you know?
And like not (expletive)
$1500 checks out here, like,
you know, in LA.
So he was like..
It also kind of baffled him,
like why the (expletive)
would you wanna be out here,
and not, you know, in Hawaii
or something making more.
And, you know, I guess it was
like the whole mental thing
you know, like, my mental
health, it was just like..
- [Interviewer] So when you
go back to LA what'd you do?
- So, got back to LA.
I was with my family for like a week.
Then they came back and
I went back with them.
I went back to the apartment,
but things were just weird at this point.
- [Interviewer] Got back to Hawaii?
- No, when we, when they
got back from Hawaii,
which was like a week after
that, after I got back.
- [Interviewer] They came back as well?
- Yeah. They came back and, you know,
they called me and I
went back to the house.
I, you know, I had never moved
out of the house, you know?
I had just came back to
LA, you know, without them.
And, when they came back to,
you know, back home to LA,
and I went back to the house,
at this point, you know it's been like,
it's been a couple of months.
It was like three months.
I guess she started to
think that I was like,
(expletive) him.
Which, I wasn't him (expletive)
because I liked him or I wanted
to like, have sex with him.
Like, obviously he was just
doing it while she was gone.
And I never said anything
about that to her.
She just, the way he would act, you know,
around us when we were
together in the same room.
And it was kind of like obvious,
and I never wanted to make it obvious,
because I didn't want her upset at me.
Like that was my friend.
She brought me in and she did this for me.
And I felt like I kind
of owed her something.
And I felt like if I, you know,
at least kept that to myself,
I felt like I was kinda doing her a favor,
cause they eventually, you know,
they eventually had a
kid and like, you know,
they had a long relationship
outside of that world, you know.
Because when they first
met they were boyfriend
and girlfriend.
And, so yeah.
Things between me and
her were just not good.
And, that was kind of, you know,
one of the reasons why I was like,
I also felt like I was doing that for her,
not so much because I
didn't wanna do it anymore.
You know?
Cause I had fun, you know,
like doing all the (expletive),
(expletive) around,
and just being like, you
know, just being crazy.
Like he wasn't a violent
person with me, you know,
he wasn't, I dunno, like I
actually respected him a lot.
I liked him a lot.
I, you know, I was thankful and grateful.
Like, I don't know if that
sounds a little like pathetic,
but I mean at the time, like
he was like, he was good to me.
You know, nothing like you
would expect, you know,
like we were young.
Like he, like I said, he
was our age, you know,
his family, like all the men
in his family were pimps.
And so, that was his thing, you know,
like that's naturally what he
would grow up to be and do.
And so he had a lot of
like mentors and stuff,
and he knew what he was doing.
Like it was, you know, I admired him.
I was like, wow, like he
legitimately knows what he's doing.
And all the girls, he had,
like he had the prettiest girls
out there, like, you
know when he did, like,
there was another, like another
Asian girl that came along.
She met us up in Hawaii,
but I never worked with her,
you know, together, like this
girl was the girl who brought
me in, she was one of my best friends.
Like I said, we like,
we went to middle school
together and stuff.
And so it was like, I
don't know I was with her.
I've just, you know, just
knowing her for so long,
and working with her and
doing all these things,
like you know, we would do
dates together and stuff.
So like, me and her were
very, very close, you know?
Like, and so, you know,
just the relationship
that I was able to have
with both of them,
not necessarily them
together, but you know,
my relationship with her and
my relationship with him,
it was nice.
Like, you know, I didn't,
there was no anger,
you know, not too much animosity,
maybe her towards me. Yes.
Like, you know, a lot of resentment,
and a lot of regret, you know?
Cause she did realize
that I kind of came in
and (expletive) things up for her.
But, so I felt like once I left, you know,
I was doing her a favor, you
know, it was kind of like,
I'm just going to leave them alone,
and let them be them together, you know.
- [Interviewer] So
where'd you go from there?
- From there, I started stripping.
And I knew the whole get
down, you know, I was like,
"Oh, I know what the (expletive)
I'm doing." You know?
And then eventually I was like,
"Wow, I never needed a pimp."
Really, whatever.
Or maybe I did, you know, I don't know.
I mean, you know, there's
so much to learn from that,
but there was stripping
and then, you know,
escorting and I guess everything
kind of just comes along
you know, it's a lifestyle, you know,
it's not something that you can just,
Oh what if I, you know, like, no,
I don't think it could
have happened overnight.
But yeah, that was that. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] And then
where are you today?
- So there's, I'm not,
I dunno if you know
about the Korean culture,
they have these things called dummies.
It's where in the Asian culture,
it's not just Korea I think,
it's like all parts of Asia, they have,
you know they have kind of
like brothel type things,
where they have, you know,
they have like these rooms,
like some of them are
like really, really fancy.
They have like rooms and like
they have the girls lining up.
And then, you know, customers
from like all over the world,
like they come and they sit in a room,
and it's like kind of like
an auction off, you know,
like they have the girls
with numbers and stuff.
And, whether it's like a
business meeting with like
you know, like, wealthy
business dudes or whatever,
like or it's just one person, you know,
they have girls,
and they basically choose you
from like a crowd of girls
you know, like who they
want to be with or whatever.
So believe it or not,
there's like something
similar to that out in LA.
They have it everywhere. They
have it in San Francisco,
they have it in New York, Vegas,
super, super, super underground.
But that's what I've been
doing for eight years now.
- [Interviewer] And this is
a pretty much exclusively
Asian clientele.
- So at the beginning
it was mostly Asians.
Now it's a little more, you know,
it's a little more diverse.
But the agency that I
work for, they are Korean.
So, but it's not just
Korean, it's Armenians,
Russians, you know, Chinese,
Thai, Filipino, you know,
there's just like white
guys and black guys.
I mean, there's literally
all sorts of people.
- [Interviewer] And this
is probably much safer than
working the street?
- Definitely. Definitely.
- [Interviewer] Did you
have some bad experiences
when you were working that way or why?
- All these years it's literally just been
one bad experience,
and drinking was an issue
for me at the beginning,
also stripping, you know, there's a lot
of drinking and stripping where
of course, like, you know,
I had my days where I was like,
(expletive) like where's
all my money. Oh my God.
And I literally like, so
I got to like, you know,
I had to teach myself, I
had to learn on my own.
Like not, you know, I mean no
one's telling you not to take
five more shots, you know?
So that was hard, you know?
But I definitely learned my
lesson and I learned it good.
Cause it could've been really bad.
But coming into the dummy world,
again there's lots of drinking, you know,
I've been kicked out of
rooms where, you know,
they ask you like, "Oh,
are you, you know, like,
what do you wanna drink today?"
And like, "Oh, like, I don't
really wanna drink today."
And like,
"Okay, well I'm gonna
have to dismiss you then."
You know?
So, you know, if you're not working,
you're not getting paid.
You know, obviously.
It's not like the agency pays you hourly.
It's like, if you're not booked,
you're not making any money.
So I can be out at the venue all day.
And like, if I don't get booked,
I'm not making any money, you know?
So, yeah.
So, never say you're not drinking
because you're not gonna make any money.
And that's like, that's one
of the biggest reasons why,
you know, people go there,
they wanna drink, you know,
that's like the biggest thing, you know?
That's how everybody kind of like,
socializes through that, you know?
And it's kind of hard not
to drink when you're dealing
with all this stuff, but...
Just, you know, you just
gotta be like moderate,
you know, pace yourself.
And yeah, the one bad
experience I can think of was,
I had been, I went to a venue.
I had like some friends that
were here from out of town,
and I was actually at one of the venues,
and I wasn't actually on the clock.
Like I wasn't with my agency,
I had just brought, I had got a table
for my friends who were out of town,
and I ended up partying with them.
But because I was still dressed, you know,
like in a cocktail dress and all that,
I looked like I was working.
I don't know what I, I
think I had just gone
to the bathroom, and I was a little drunk.
So I was kinda like, you
know, stumbling a little bit.
And I was like two doors from my room.
And these two huge, like Russian guys,
like kind of like hovered over me.
And they're like, "Hey,
like, what are you doing?"
And the venue wasn't so busy that night.
It was like, it was actually after hours.
They have lots of after hours, you know,
shindigs that they do.
And so it was late, you know,
maybe like four or five in the morning,
the venue wasn't too busy.
There was a lot of empty rooms.
And they were like, "Oh,
like, what are you doing?"
It was just those two guys.
And there's like, nobody in
the hallways and you know,
not really, everything's
just kind of happening
you know, like, "Oh, not doing anything.
I'm just going back to my room."
Like, "Oh, like you want
to come hang out with us?"
And like the guy, like, he
like pulls out like 500 bucks,
and he was just like, kinda
like shoves it down my bra.
And I'm like, okay, cool.
Like, I'm like, I'm just
gonna take this and go like,
and but next thing I know,
like one of the guys, like,
you know,
and he like kind of swung the door open,
and the other guy shoved me in,
and of the guys ran in behind me,
and the other guide like
closed the door behind him.
And so I was like stuck in
this room with this guy.
And had it not been for one
of the waiters walking by
within a minute of that happening,
pretty sure I would have
been raped, like a 100%.
But I was able to like bang
the (expletive), you know,
the window. Cause like the
doors have like little glass
like windows. So, I bang the door,
and the guy like kind of saw
me like struggling in there.
And he came in and he opened the door,
and he was like, you know,
like, and the guys tried to say
that like I stole their money,
but I was like, you know,
by then I was like crying, you know, like,
and I was obviously like super scared.
And obviously that's
not what had happened.
Obviously I..
How was I going to take
this 500 bucks from them?
You know, like, and yeah,
they got kicked out and I mean,
they said, sorry, like, wow.
You know, but yeah.
The cool thing about that
is, about these places is,
there is no security. Okay.
There's no security. There's
no telling if you're gonna
get paid or not, you know,
that night or the next night,
you know?
You just kind of have to, you know,
be good at reading people, I guess.
And just hope that, you know like,
you entertain them enough,
that they're not gonna walk
away without paying you because,
who's to say that, you know,
you're not gonna be in this
room with these four guys
for three hours and they're
not just gonna get up
and walk away and not pay you, right?
And so when there's incidents like that,
you know, that's why we have,
that's why we work for agencies, you know?
And I say, quote on
quote, because, you know,
it's just like a, you know,
a group of like Korean
guys that, you know,
kind of just like they say, you know,
like we'll be there if you
need any help or whatever.
But I mean, they just
come in and say like,
"Come on, you need to
pay her", you know, like,
and then the customers
always make some stupid
(expletive) excuse as to why
they don't wanna (expletive)
pay you or whatever.
And then there'll be like,
they'll eventually pay you like half
of what they're really
supposed to pay you,
and you still have to
pay the house, you know,
you still have to pay,
you know, your dues or whatever,
but doesn't happen as
often as you would imagine.
So that's cool.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs or
alcohol a part of your life?
- Yeah. When working, you
know, I don't like to drink.
I've always like been a weed smoker.
I guess Xanax.
Like my anxiety is usually
like through the roof a lot.
I have an issue, I guess, with anxiety.
So, but, you know, Xanax
and alcohol don't mix.
So, I've kind of stopped
a lot with the Xanax,
because I know that I
have to drink for work.
Like, I'd rather drink
than take a Xanax bar,
because the Xanax bar will
black me out all night,
and a drink won't so,
and there's a lot of the
girls that do work are like,
you know, they're like sober, you know,
they don't take Xanax or
smoke weed or excuse me.
And so like, you know,
you see all the girls that
are not taking Xanax bars
and like, you know, popping
pills and taking ecstasy.
And it's like, there's
a lot of competition,
you know you don't want to
be the junky girl or whatever
you know, like, so I think that's cool.
You know, I can look around
me and be like, okay, like,
make sure I'm not like
(expletive) up, you know?
Like, so I mean, I enjoy it.
I've met a lot of cool people,
lots of cool people,
and people are respectful.
Some people are not, some people are rude,
but I think that's just
anywhere in any job,
you know like, I'm just
used to making fast money.
And I think that's just
the only thing I'm ever
gonna be used to.
- [Interviewer] Does this
lifestyle ever get you depressed?
- Sometimes.
But there's more like happy
times than suppressing times.
So, I just try to not drink
too much and not wake up
like, what the (expletive)
happened last night.
That's definitely gonna depress you.
Yeah. So, I mean, it's been years.
I, you know, I-
- [Interviewer] What advice
would you give to a young girl
that's considering doing
something like this?
- Just don't lose focus of
what you're really doing
this for, you know, which
is, I would hope the money,
you know, it's, you're here for the money.
Like, don't forget that,
then the night you have to
make sure you have a certain
amount of money or that
you go home with money
in your pocket.
Like, don't get too (expletive) drunk.
Don't get too caught up in, you know,
like partying because that's what it is.
You know, everybody likes to
distract you with like drugs,
and alcohol, and coke,
and, you know, ecstasy,
and next thing you know, you
know, you don't get paid.
So, I think those were
the only times where
I was just like, (expletive)
like, what am I doing?
You know, like when I'd go home,
and I'd have no (expletive) money to show
for (expletive) eight hours, you know?
So just, don't get too drunk.
Don't get too drunk,
and just keep your money in a safe place.
- [Interviewer] Are you saving money now?
- Yes and no.
Not as much as I should probably.
Not as much as like, you know,
compared to like what I make,
you know, in a week.
Like, I definitely don't
like, I spend a lot, you know,
like, I have like a shopping addiction.
Like it's an addiction.
Like it's bad,
but I definitely need
to work on that saving,
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- I'm sorry.
- Yes, I do. I do.
I have a five-year-old.
- [Interviewer] And are
you raising your child?
- So his dad passed away
from a drug overdose
three years ago.
That was the only time that
I stepped away from working,
you know, dummy.
And we were together
for, I left, you know,
I left work for like two
years because he didn't,
he was a business owner,
and we planned it,
you know, we plan to have kids and stuff,
but then yeah, he overdid it,
and I literally woke
up to his body one day,
and I kinda like lost my mind, you know,
I kind of lost my (expletive).
And I just, you know,
at the time I just realized
that the best thing
for my kid at the time was to
sign my rights over to my mom.
Because I just mentally
was not capable, you know?
And I know that as much
as it hurts me, I mean,
it's painful, you know?
Because like we planned it,
you know, we planned on,
like it wasn't like, "Oh,
I just got pregnant."
Like, no, like we, this was all
thought out and planned out.
And so, yeah, it's painful
to know that, you know,
I'm not raising my son, and his dad,
my husband's dad passed away
when he was young, you know,
he grew up without a dad.
So, when we had our kid, you
know, that was like his thing.
Like he wanted us to raise them, you know,
be parents, like be there for his son.
And so when he passed away,
like, I just wasn't able
to do that, you know?
And that's the painful part about that.
But I mean, I see my son,
and he's good where he is.
Right now my mom,
my mom's amazing for that,
you know, taking care of him.
And she took the responsibility
and it hasn't been easy,
but she, you know, she
didn't abandon me or Maxwell.
So,
I'm grateful for that.
You know, have my mom
helping me with that.
I mean, I hope in the long
run, I can, I don't know,
get him back or something back on,
because she hasn't adopted, like,
I just signed my rights over to her.
So, we'll see what happens.
- [Interviewer] Do you see her?
- I do. She lives in Korea town.
And, but once I signed over my rights,
there was, social workers
got involved and stuff,
and because, you know,
we had a dispensary and
because of him passing away
from a drug overdose,
they really got involved.
You know, they were making sure
that I wasn't on drugs
and I wasn't around him.
So, it turned into this
whole other ordeal, you know,
with Child Services.
So, I had so much going on
with my husband's passing
that dealing with all the
social workers was just not
in my deck of cards.
So, I just decided to kind
of just like pull away
from that whole picture and scenario.
I just couldn't deal with social workers.
I would lash out.
And I just, I was like,
I'm just gonna end up
(expletive) saying something
stupid.
I'm gonna (expletive) this up for my son,
and they're gonna take
my kid away from my mom,
just because, you know, they're,
you know, they're really insensitive.
I just..
It was just crazy how, you know,
I had a social worker
trying to tell me how to,
I guess raise my kid,
when this person had no kids.
So, none of that made any sense to me,
and I just didn't wanna
make the situation worse.
And so I just decided to,
just gonna sign my rights over,
and I'm just gonna like, you know,
try and work on my mental health,
and just knowing that my kid's okay, like,
you know, that's okay for now.
- [Interviewer] How do
you think all these years
of doing this for a
living has changed you?
- I think I've become very,
I don't wanna say cold,
but I'm just like,
I don't really like to deal with,
it's like,
I don't like to deal
with people who just kind
of talk a lot and just, you know,
they have nothing to show for anything or,
you know just,
I'd rather you show me then,
you know, tell me, you know,
and if you're not gonna show
me, then (expletive) off.
- [Interviewer] You think this has changed
the way you view men?
- I mean I've never had a
certain view on men, you know,
I don't have a type or anything.
I've met a lot of men, but I
feel like just like with women,
there's a lot of really stupid girls,
and there's a lot of dumb blonde girls,
and a lot of smart blonde girls.
And I think it's, I
don't know when you find,
when you do meet somebody
interesting, that's cool.
You know, it's nice to like, you know,
you can get to know them,
and it's not just like
a dead end, you know,
I just don't really put up
with too much (expletive).
I'm super like,
everybody says like I'm
just super straightforward.
Like, you know, I just
kind of tell it how it is.
And I think, yeah, my lifestyle
has definitely made that
you know, a thing for me,
like just you can't beat
around the bush, you know,
don't waste my time.
Don't waste your time
and don't waste my time.
So,
but again,
I don't regret anything, you know,
I think I'm okay, for now.
You know, I don't think...
I think I could have been, you know,
somewhere worse than where I am right now,
and I think I did good,
you know, for myself.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Thank you for listening.
- [Interviewer] Very interesting.
- Thanks.